foreign
they started they [__] up when they
didn't let the midgets be in the movie
that's when they [__] up yeah I saw
that picture and I was like wait why is
it all regular gut not not regular I
shouldn't say regular you can't say
regular that's not right okay yeah you
mean you non-monsters is the PC term
[__] [__] humans
um no cause even like Hornswoggle from
WWE played it on the show he was like
yeah man that could have been like seven
like [__] actors that could have had a
job like I want to be in a Disney movie
I want the residuals but Peter Dinklage
who by the way only is famous because
he's a [__] from Game of Thrones
decided to come out and be like you know
what they really meant to should it just
be cast and midgets in these things like
[__] you bro you made all your money
already [__] off yeah these regular
height guys are appropriating [__]
culture not cool dude it's not you know
what it's not we should fight for
midgets we need to bring back Major
bowling [__] bowling needs to come
back
um that's fun yeah it's awesome as long
as we can keep him out of strip clubs
dude I like I I thought I would enjoy a
[__] strip show and I hated it wait
have you seen you've seen him it's a
trip show
oh yeah how was it loaded up on
oxycontin and it was you were there was
this ever can I ask was this a specific
[__] that was kind of famous
it was weird dude because one of them
was just like a normal lady but she was
like a 50 year old like looked like a
like a definite lifelong smoker and she
was just real small so that was the
first act and then the second act was an
actual an actual little person dressed
up as Christina Aguilera I got thrown
out because I like I had a meltdown
yeah it was bad hold on a couple things
we're all trash because the moment Murr
said a famous one we both knew Bridget
so we know what guard we know what level
of garbage we're at as I worked with
Bridget the [__] she was a feature
twice at clubs I was at did you no God
no I don't know for the stories she's a
[__] mess bro yeah she's a [__] not
so many knuckles I don't get where all
the knuckles come from it's crazy how do
you have fat Guyanese when you're that
tiny it doesn't make sense it's weird
but there's also different like levels
of midgets right like there's the ones
that are really short but they have kind
of normal proportions but they're the
ones that look like little fat babies
the ones you're talking about there's a
little because there's dwarfism and then
there's just tiny chicks yeah there's
little chicks but they're called Mexican
okay
um that's yeah that's what we call them
out so that yeah but they're very
they're very little but I don't
understand why did you get kicked out
did you scream at Christina aguiler or
the [__] yeah yeah I started I started
yelling like I was unhappy it wasn't
what I was expecting uh I was pretty
Disturbed and I just started screaming
no at her and I was like at the stage
and I just started screaming no no no
and yeah they uh they dragged me out I
saw that
we would have dragged him out you
violently scream no
yeah just pointing at her screaming no I
wasn't you know roasting her or anything
I wasn't saying anything rude per se but
yeah I mean I've done some wild [__] in
strip clubs that was like one of the
Lesser wild things that I've ever done
uh and they threw me out immediately I I
I I know you said something there that
was like it's not what I was expecting
sir yeah what were you expecting from
him I don't know I was so excited for
this show too like I was hyped I brought
two of my buddies with me I bought all
the covers because they were kind of
like I don't know if this is really what
I want to do with my Saturday and I was
like no guys it's a [__] strip show we
have to go like this is crucial yeah and
so I thought it was going to be super
fun and I don't know if it was just
because I I did too many drugs probably
that might have had something to do with
it
I was just beside myself dude I was I
like so like the fact that I had a seat
at the stage I got there early like I
was ready for it and then when they
actually came out I was just something
something triggered inside me I was like
this is not what I wanted this is what I
expected I don't like this
so okay what which I have to ask was she
dressed like like the dirty video like
is that is that I knew it I know you had
like the little page Boy hat on
uh and like like some flared jeans I
remember this vividly this is how much
it stuck with me how much I hated it uh
but yeah it was like full on Christina
Aguilera so so it wasn't this one though
right I found this
why they're not even white passing
Hispanic woman you look nothing like
like even forget the [__] part it's
more than just a blonde Party City wig
what happened to Jay Leno when did they
shrink him down holy [__] that is so
[__] have you heard about this Kevin
have you seen this Kevin you know it's
Britney Spears uh you know maybe she
should stay in the conservative Kevin I
cloned myself in name he's trans now
dude that looks like a Barbie party too
absolutely every party is the Barbie
party if you believe this is so
disrespectful
Christina Aguilera oh that Sky that's
like a nightmare right that's a night
there it is
see I was always a Christina over
Britney guy so this is disrespectful to
Christina again holy [__] this is
hilarious I mean I guess there would be
[__] versions of everything I mean you
make money that way
and that's how they bill it too like
they call it you know [__] wrestling
[__] strip show oh so this isn't like
me using a slur
um I mean I think most midgets don't
even care you know most actual midgets
don't even care if you use the term
[__] from what I've ones that I've
talked to they don't [__] care you
know some of them still go out like the
[__] wrestlers and they're like yes
this is [__] wrestling that's what it
is called absolutely we are trying to
sell tickets and we're not trying to
[__] lose ticket sales because little
person no we're calling me Micro
wrestling no one's going to that yeah
you just think there's a bunch of babies
yeah he's the guy that did Dirty Jobs
um actually the micro wrestling guys
like I think it's Mike micro oh micro so
what about see now I'm making stupid
jokes what about what about hear me out
little Britney Spears what about little
Britney Spears
[Applause]
oh until I saw her like I was like until
I saw the legs it's the legs right it's
happening they look like the turkey legs
you buy the Renaissance Fair they look
like upside down tubes of toothpaste oh
God it does look like something you'd
buy like at a renaissance fair to eat
yeah it is exactly you'd walk around
with one in your hand be like well these
are delicious yeah it's a mutton their
legs look like muttons